[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde l'identité et le territoire il
y a Paris et la province deux entités en
rivalité d'influence de développement
économique et pour savoir où il fait
meilleur vivre il y a la Normandie et la
Bretagne l'Auvergne Rhône-Alpes et
l'Occitanie et d'autres grandes régions
dont l'individualité profonde
anthropologique et socioculturelle est
en constante évolution parfois avec des
regroupements sans cohérence
territoriale ou économique la
mondialisation a rebattu les cartes du
village planétaire avec le télétravail
les mobilités découlant de la transition
énergétique et de la révolution
numérique avec aussi des services
publics plus ou moins performants des
trappes résidentielles et des trappes
scolaires la montée des communautarismes
des reprises identitaires et des
violences des révoltes qui se propage on
se souvient des bonnets rouges et plus
récemment des gilets jaunes sur fond
d'inégalités sociales et de
désindustrialisations pardon des
territoires tout cela contribue à faire
émerger des revendications
identitaires liées à la proximité et la
distance les traditions et la modernité
la religion et les migrations les mœurs
et jusqu'au vote qui prend un caractère
anthropologique un véritable archipel
des identités que nous allons chercher à
discerner avec mes invités que je vous
présente Hélène pesquine vous êtes
architecte urbaniste secrétaire général
dupucca Jean-Pierre Lecoq vous êtes
maire du sixième arrondissement de Paris
Eric Piol vous êtes maire de Grenoble et
nous vous avons en visio-conférence
Juliette mais Adèle vous êtes femme
politique an ministre et Jacques Lévy
vous aime universitaire et géographe
[Musique]
il y a Paris et la province au-delà de
cette évidence géographique qu'est-ce
qu'il est distingue en termes généraux
on va rentrer dans le détail mais si
vous avez un point de discrimination
entre Paris et la province c'est pour
vous lequel Jean-Pierre Lecoq je
rappelle que vous êtes maire du 6e
arrondissement à Paris
le français et je ne confonds pas le
sixième arrondissement avec la totalité
des totalités de l'Île-de-France voir
avec la province ça reste un bel
arrondissement ça reste un bel
arrondissement ça reste l'arrondissement
du Sénat du Luxembourg mais si vous
voulez c'est un arrondissement pétri
d'histoire mais je suis aussi originaire
de l'Aisne à 100 km de Paris vous avez
un département rural en même temps qui
était industriel qui ne l'était plus on
a tous les tous les clignotants sociaux
sont au rouge dans l'Aisne oui mais sur
Paris
pour vous qui distingue c'est maintenant
et c'est de plus en plus notable si vous
voulez c'est une cette éloignement nos
compatriotes de province des services
publics c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a
eu cette réforme cette révolte des des
gilets jaunes et également la raison
pour laquelle on a le sentiment que le
gouvernement est très attentif
effectivement au revendications qui
peuvent naître du fait notamment de la
hausse du coût de l'énergie et de la
hausse des prix de l'essence car en
province on a souvent besoin de sa
voiture on a quelques fois même besoin
de deux voitures très bien alors qu'à
Paris on peut circuler à vélo mais tous
les parisiens et les Parisiennes ne
peuvent pas circuler à vélo Eric Piol
vous vous devez je suis désolé vous êtes
à la fois à Paris et en province mais
disons que pour nous vous êtes monsieur
province au cours de cette émission
qu'est-ce qui distingue pour vous en
termes très généraux Paris à la province
la concentration de des centres de
pouvoir qui a à Paris et donc du coup
une certaine consanguanité de ces
centres de pouvoir rien que la façon
dont vous décrivez Paris et la province
nous on ne se vit pas en province on ne
se vit pas parisien mais c'est évident
quand on est à Grenoble on ne se vit pas
pareil que quand on est à Bordeaux quand
on est dans mes Pyrénées natales quand
on est dans le Nord et donc la province
il n'y a que vous qui parlez de province
en fait le reste de du pays vit
différemment et
vit une concentration des pouvoirs des
centres de décision à Paris
quand on vous demande
Eric Piol en trois mots de vous définir
vous dites quoi
pas comme promotion en fait
on n'a pas de problème de service public
en province ça n'a pas de sens il y a
des bassins urbains qui ont tous les
services publics de la terre et il y a
des zones périphériques rurales qui ont
des problèmes de connexion de mobilité
de connexion numérique de connexion au
service public donc nous nous
définissons
aujourd'hui à Grenoble on se définit
comme grenoblois quand on vit dans un
bassin de 700 000 habitants on se
définit comme montagnard parce qu'on est
parce qu'on est là au cœur des Alpes et
donc c'est ça qui fait notre
identité mais on ne se définit pas trop
par notre identité et plus parce que
l'on fait mais pour parler de mes
racines moi Basco béarnaises quand je
suis chez moi je vais y être là dans mon
village pour les fêtes de Noël là on va
se définir tout autrement on se définit
par les racines parce qu'on est notre
essence et notre histoire et moins parce
que l'on fait et donc c'est un autre
rapport au territoire qui est totalement
différent de celui qu'on vit à Grenoble
et de celui que vous pouvez vivre à
Paris très bien alors écoutez on va
essayer quand même de rentrer dans le
détail selon le sociologue Pierre
Bourdieu la province peut-être définie
par la distance sociale économique et
culturelle avec Paris qui brille de
mille feux est-ce que à votre avis
hélène pesquine se retard a-t-il été
rattrapé et inversement est-ce que Paris
n'est pas pénalisé par la
désindustrialisation qui est en cours
depuis plusieurs décennies
alors moi je dirais qu'il y a plusieurs
paris dans votre pari en fait Paris
c'est à la fois un peu la France c'est
Paris la ville capitale qui représente
une certaine manière qui est un peu
assimilée à la France et puis il y a le
Paris le territoire parisien et
francilien ça a été évoqué mais
l'Île-de-France n'est pas Paris non plus
en fait quand on regarde à l'échelle de
la région d'influence de l'ère
métropolitaine de Paris on a des
différences territoriales qui sont
fortes et sociales et socio-sociales qui
sont très fortes de l'approche banlieue
jusqu'à la très lointaine
périphérie urbaine donc il y a peut-être
déjà à distinguer un peu de quel pari on
parle on parle on a cette espèce d'image
du Paris des élites qui est un pari
plutôt sociologique et qui est celui qui
a un peu réfuté par un certain nombre de
territoires en région qui disent mais
nous aussi on a notre capacité de faire
centralité d'avoir des services à
proximité des université des grandes
fonctions internationales etc et ça
peut-être à une dimension moindre que
qu'à Paris mais en tout cas ça existe
aussi ailleurs en France bien entendu et
de manière différenciée qu'on soit à
Bordeaux à Lille à à Marseille et puis
il y a le Paris vécu des Parisiens je
pense que les élus ici en parleront
mieux que moi mais qui est celui d'une
réalité territoriale avec aussi des
difficultés sociales et spatiales qui se
qui se révèlent au quotidien et qui
n'est un peu disjointe finalement de ce
pari des élites et du centre de décision
qui effectivement est une réalité aussi
qui peut donner l'impression à une
grande partie des Français d'ailleurs
que les décisions sont prises un peu
hors-sol puisqu'on est sur la question
des territoires et donc dans une espèce
de sphère politique qu'aux peut-être
médiatico
institutionnel qui est un peu dans
l'entre-soi en effet parce que c'est la
concentration de tous les pouvoirs dans
la alors Paris province Juliette meradel
vous êtes à la fois de Paris et de
banlieue puisque vous êtes parisienne et
lu de Montrouge
quelle distinction vous faites est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que quand
vous traversez le périphérique vous
n'êtes plus dans Paris écoutez oui
complètement ça peut vous paraître
bizarre mais mon rouge est une ville
limitrophe de Paris et quand je traverse
le périph et que j'arrive à Montrouge
c'est pas la même chose
il faut dire que Paris est quand même la
ville qui concentre une incroyable
quantité de richesse et de pouvoir et
que de ce fait vous avez quand même des
services publics en termes d'offre
sanitaire en termes d'offres scolaire en
termes de transport en terme d'accès
même à la sécurité parce que vous avez
un nombre de policiers grâce à la
préfecture de police de Paris qui est
infiniment plus important que dans
n'importe quel autre ville de province
donc Paris concentre quand même un accès
à un service public confortable vous
avez Paris et même la région
Île-de-France qui concentre l'essentiel
des plus gros sièges d'entreprise qui a
un réseau de transport quand même
important et donc moi je trouve que du
point de vue du citoyen je comprends le
citoyen qui vit dans une ville quelle
qu'elle soit qui n'est pas Paris et qui
se dit quand même et à Montrouge nous le
vivons elle va quand même c'est pas
pareil vous voyez par exemple sur le ce
qu'on appelle le périscolaire il y a
plus d'argent à Paris donc les enfants
qui vont à l'école à Paris ils ont plus
d'argent il y a plus d'activités
scolaires il y a plus d'animaux on va
rentrer dans le détail donc c'est quand
même ça la différence je trouve
de richesse vous qui connaissez bien ces
questions de justice spatiale est-ce
qu'il y a une injustice spatiale entre
Paris et le reste de la il y en a une
elle est tout détriment de Paris c'est à
dire de l'Île-de-France en fait quand je
dis Paris je veux dire l'aire urbaine de
Paris mais y compris à certains égards
même de Paris intra-muros qui qui
concentre autant de pauvres que
l'ensemble des pauvres qui se trouvent
dans en dehors des aires urbaines donc
sur une immense surface mais on va leur
absolue on n'a pas plus que dans Paris
c'est à dire que les grandes les grandes
villes en général à concentre à la fois
la richesse et la pauvreté et c'est
particulièrement le cas en France pour
Paris quand je dis Paris je veux dire
l'aire urbaine de Paris c'est à dire 13
millions d'habitants Paris intra-muros
un quartier enfin c'est quelques
quartiers de la métropole pour qu'on se
comprend qu'on se comprenne bien et donc
en fait
l'Ile-de-France qui correspond à peu
près à cette erreur urbaine un petit peu
moins avec 12 millions d'habitants elle
produit 700 milliards par an de PIB et
donc plus de 30% de la production
nationale mais si une fois que tous les
prélèvements sont faits en fait elle
n'est plus qu'à peine au niveau de sa
part dans la population active
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait toute la
surproductivité de ce qui est en effet
plus concentré en Île-de-France toutes
les professions qu'on appelle créatives
vous n'êtes pas
disparaît en fait par la grosse machine
opaque de redistribution qui fait que en
gros comme en plus le prix du foncier et
particulièrement élevé la logique dans
une grande ville
quand vous êtes
fonctionnaire par exemple petit
fonctionnaire à Paris comme vous gagnez
à peu près la même chose que si vous
étiez dans une petite ville en fait vous
êtes plus pauvre donc le niveau de
pauvreté il est aussi plus élevé plus
fort vous êtes Paris en Île-de-France
donc en fait globalement si on regarde
les chiffres globaux en fait les
Franciliens sont plutôt plus pauvres que
la moyenne de la France métropolitaine
alors qu'en fait il produisent beaucoup
plus donc il y a bien une injustice
Jean-Pierre Lecoq vous êtes d'accord
je suis totalement d'accord si vous
voulez je suis totalement d'accord il y
a un vrai problème pour tous les agents
de catégorie C qui sont qui sont
les agents d'exécution
un cadre à dirige un cadre B assis le
cadre A et un cadre C c'est à dire un
agent de catégorie C exécute et par
définition ce sont des gens d'ailleurs
qu'on a glorifié au moment de la
pandémie
le télétravail n'est pas possible pour
eux d'ailleurs je rappelle que 80 et 90
% des postes dans une collectivité
territoriale ne sont pas télétravables
agents des services des traitements des
ordures auxiliaires de puéricultrice etc
etc donc ces gens-là ont donné beaucoup
de même ils habitent maintenant du fait
de l'évaluation du prix du foncier à
Paris le prix du mètre carré a doublé en
15 ans et ça a été la même chose pour
les loyers et d'ailleurs ça s'étend à
toute la première et la deuxième
couronne en été ça s'étend à toute la
zone dense alors la zone dense c'est à
peu près c'est l'ancien département de
la Seine 7 millions d'habitants donc ces
gens-là qui gagnent ou le SMIC ou
légèrement au-dessus ils habitent à
combien 40 50 km de Paris voir dans
l'Oise dans l'Aisne etc ils sont soumis
aux aléas des transports en pas besoin
de développer et au bout de 15 ans 20
ans 25 ans ils sont usés donc un taux de
15% actuellement de 12 à 15% du
personnel municipal parisien qui est en
arrêt maladie ou en difficulté c'est pas
étonnant en disant ça je ne dénonce
personne il faut que Paris loge beaucoup
plus ceux et celles qui travaillent pour
les Parisiens alors écoutez les agents
de catégorie on va essayer de d'aller
beaucoup de communes de on va essayer
d'aller un peu plus loin et de voir ce
que représente l'attachement d'un
territoire pour ses citoyens on a une
carte c'est le baromètre de
l'attachement à sa région durant la
pandémie de covid des milliers de
Parisiens sont allés en province pour se
mettre aux abris selon la formule mais
aussi par désaffection pour Paris est-il
exact monsieur Piol que René un pardon
une nouvelle fierté régionale et a
contrario comme vous l'avez entendu
moins d'attractivité pour les grandes
métropoles et notamment Paris pour nous
direz qu'est-ce qui vous attache à votre
région puisque c'est il y a des régions
auxquelles on est beaucoup plus attaché
par exemple la Bretagne et beaucoup
moins par exemple la région PACA mais
peut-être que vous nous direz dans votre
carronnade qu'est-ce qui fait que vous
êtes attaché à cette région et un
commentaire là-dessus
oui je peux commencer par ça d'abord
Ronald c'est très grand donc aujourd'hui
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes ça va d'Aurillac à
Thonon-les-Bains donc oui il faut 8
heures de voiture pour traverser
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes donc la région
administrative telle que vous l'entendez
n'a plus de sens ni en termes de culture
historique ni en termes de proximité de
mode de vie ce qui m'attache moi
pourquoi je suis arrivé ici à 20 ans
depuis mes Pyrénées et que j'y suis
resté c'est évidemment les montagnes
très attachées aux montagnes et très
attachées à une taille de ville qui
permet à la fois un bouillonnement une
innovation une capacité à mélanger les
gens et une voilà une richesse de vie
culturelle de vie économique des
travailler 18 ans dans l'industrie ici
on peut effectivement travailler pendant
longtemps changer l'entreprise continuer
à évoluer donc c'est ça qui m'attache à
la terre à la fois l'environnement la
montagne et puis cette capacité à se
mélanger dans une taille de permet des
déplacements forts les Parisiens ils
viennent pas depuis Paris dans des
endroits où qui restent du monde urbain
mais qui sont éloignés nous on est à 3h
de TGV un tout petit peu moins de Paris
c'est trop loin pour aller travailler de
tout les jours donc on peut y aller
toutes les semaines mais tous les jours
c'est compliqué et donc on n'a pas été
envahi de Parisiens qui ont il y a pas
de résidence secondaire ici assez peu
par contre on a vu effectivement
depuis Grenoble Centre par exemple des
des gens qui ont cherché à retrouver un
contact avec la nature et donc acheter
des maisons à l'extérieur est-ce que
vous constatez ça au plus cas dans le
laboratoire que vous animez Ellen
pesquine s'est attachement on est obligé
de dire la province puisque c'est un
terme générique et avec une désaffection
pour Paris c'est la fois vrai et pas
vrai c'est à dire que Paris est toujours
la métropole capitale et continue
d'attirer beaucoup notamment des jeunes
actifs des étudiants mais aussi des
jeunes actifs et des jeunes ménages
disons début de leur vie familiale la
difficulté qu'à soulever
j'en parle Lecoq c'est que effectivement
au bout d'un moment on est un peu coincé
par ces capacité de pouvoir d'achat et
donc d'accéder au logement et donc il y
a un grand nombre de Parisiens arriver
plutôt à l'âge du premier du deuxième ou
du 3e enfant qui se qui se desserre
d'une certaine manière de la ville
centre et qui donc perdent un peu de
cette qualité de vie d'accès aux
services à la culture à l'emploi qui
pouvait donc il pouvait bénéficier au
bénéfices d'un logement plus grand plus
adapté à leur réalité familiale et donc
on a à la fois un effet d'attraction un
effet de répulsion effectivement les
travaux qu'on a qu'on a conduit sur les
effets du covid sur l'immigration
résidentielle montre qu'il y a pas du
tout d'exode massif des villes vers les
campagnes ça n'existe pas c'est c'est un
peu une vue de l'esprit ou d'une
certaine catégorie professionnelle
notamment professionnelle journaliste
etc qui ont fait ce sauter dans la
résidence secondaire bien souvent
pendant la crise et qui sont restés
c'est pas du tout un fait général par
contre on a un effet un peu de
desserrement je dirais en cascade depuis
les très grandes villes compris les
métropoles régionales vers leur
périphérie voire vers des petites villes
ou des villes moyennes disons et puis
deux villes moyennes vers des petites
villes avec un toujours un peu la même
réflexion de se dire je veux me
rapprocher de la nature je veux être
plus près d'un environnement serein
après la crise qu'on a traversé et donc
c'est en fait un effet en cascade les
Parisiens ont pu quitter relativement
nombreux pour Paris c'est relativement
significatif le centre-ville pour aller
vers Bordeaux ou vers Grenoble ou vers
Marseille ou vernis Nice et pas vers le
village de 40 habitants où on va refaire
sa vie sous une forme un peu plus
marginale ou un peu plus proche de la
nature en revanche dans chaque strat
finalement territoriale on a un peu ce
phénomène un phénomène un peu de rejet
de la vie quotidienne qu'on a eu pendant
le confinement qui a été très violente
et donc on cherche un peu ailleurs et on
cherche plutôt dans la strat inférieur
démographique inférieur alors Monsieur
le puisque personne défend Paris je
pensais que vous alliez le faire mais
est-ce que vous pouvez dire est-ce si
Paris s'est dégradé ces dernières
décennies est-ce que Paris a perdu en
attractivité sur le plan culturel on le
constate pas des grandes expositions se
font à Paris
les grands événements culturels se font
également à Paris est-ce qu'il y a
concrètement une perte d'attractivité et
où vous la situez mais là je vais
répondre également de façon aussi
mesurée qu'elle a une pesquine elle a eu
tout à fait raison de son ami
ce que vous pensez
mais là je vais voir une réponse
politique mais effectivement j'ajoute
que Paris reste également excessivement
attractif pour les pour les étrangers
évidemment d'étrangers d'où les
phénomènes de résidence secondaire qu'on
retrouve notamment dans l'Ouest parisien
après le problème c'était déjà le cas la
fuite des familles après un ou deux
enfants c'est-à-dire d'ailleurs vous
aviez des arrondissements centraux vers
les arrondissements périphériques puis
de la périphérie vers la première et
deuxième couronne le covid effectivement
accéléré tout ça même si ma simple il
semblerait que maintenant il y a un
nouveau il y a une certaine retour à
Paris et le ce qui est très fort sur
Paris et dire c'est le cas bien
évidemment dispense c'est les la qualité
des écoles et diversités et ça on
lootera jamais à Paris ça c'est très
fort en revanche il est clair que vous
aidez des gens qui consistent qui
maintenant en considère que l'espace
public parisien n'est pas au niveau il
devrait être propreté sécurité et
d'ailleurs à la veille des Jeux
Olympiques et alors que Paris reste une
destination touristique excessivement
importante les Asiatiques n'étant pas
encore revenus j'attire vraiment
l'attention de tous les responsables sur
le problème de la sécurité on ne peut
pas continuer à faire venir des
touristes qui se font contrôler leur
montre voir tabasser entre Roissy et le
centre de la capitale c'est pas possible
car ça si vous voulez c'est relayer dans
le monde entier donc il y a un problème
effectivement la mairie de Paris la
ville de Paris les élus de Paris de la
métropole doivent se concentrer beaucoup
plus sur la qualité de l'espace public
j'ajoute enfin que après la covid Paris
est considéré comme maintenant comme
beaucoup de Parisiens et sa conduit
également alors départ de la capitale
comme une ville très dense on va avoir
un maintenant un débat excessivement
important ou printemps prochain sur le
PLU sur le plan lequel d'urbanisme et
moi je plaide maintenant pour un pari où
il n'y aurait plus de il y aurait plus
de d'accroissement de la densité les
Parisiens après la covid veulent
effectivement respirer un meilleur air
et également avoir un environnement qui
soit plus agréable votre point de vue
Juliette mais Adèle VOD qui est en
transfrontière si je puis dire comment
vous êtes vous appréciez
dégradation dont on parle Jean-Pierre
Lecoq mais je serai pas aussi négative
que vous c'est à dire que je crois que
chaque ville en plus a quand même sa
particularité son histoire et elle est
très dépendante de la personnalité de
son maire je trouve moi qui c'est quand
même dégradé à Paris c'est propre à son
attractivité comme vous l'avez souligné
c'est l'incapacité de la Méria actuelle
à gérer les flux importants de tourisme
à gérer la question des transports
c'est-à-dire que en dépit des pistes
cyclables qui ont amené du bon dans la
vie quotidienne il y a toujours
énormément d'embouteillages d'écart avec
des énormément de touristes et sans
contrôle suffisant des entrées et des
sorties moi je considère que il faudrait
prendre des mesures pour installer des
quotas de tourisme parce que c'est comme
à Venise on va Venise on a une sur une
surconsommation touristique qui dégrade
des bâtiments on a un patrimoine
exceptionnel à Paris qui se dégrade donc
je je trouve qu'il y a à la fois une
attractivité importante et des mesures
qui sont pas prises pour protéger la
ville après en termes de service public
je suis plus nuancée que que vous
Monsieur le Maire parce que je trouve
qu'il y a quand même à Paris des offres
d'extrême de qualité exceptionnelle
enfin il y a des grands très grands
lycées parisiens qui restent au top il y
a des très grands hôpitaux je pense à
l'hôpital Necker je pense à deux briques
il y a quand même des spécialisations
avec du top niveau il y a des très
grandes universités dans plus largement
que Paris donc on a quand même quelque
chose ce qui fait la réussite de la
France on le trouve quand même aussi et
encore toujours à Paris et en
Île-de-France ce qui à mon avis fait le
plus défauts c'est cette capacité
finalement à élever le niveau moyen de
service public pour tous parce que Paris
c'est aussi la ville des contrastes
c'est la ville du pouvoir enfin c'est la
vie qui concentre le gouvernement le
Parlement les grandes sociétés du CAC 40
c'est la ville qui concentre la richesse
mais en même temps le niveau moyen du
service public il est même pour tous et
donc c'est dans cette direction que à
mon avis que devrait travailler la nuit
oui Jacques Lévy allez-y c'est la ville
des pouvoirs sauf celui des Parisiens
des Franciliens puisque en fait il y a
une malédiction de l'auto-gouvernement
des Parisiens depuis depuis très
longtemps notamment depuis la Troisième
République où l'accord entre les
notables ruraux et l'État central
c'était de priver les grandes villes
d'un véritable gouvernement
avec plusieurs dispositifs
constitutionnels qui ont qui ont bien
joué leur rôle alors des choses se sont
améliorées pour les grandes villes autre
que Paris personnellement j'utilise pas
la notion de province parce que je pense
que désormais justement l'espace hors de
Paris c'est beaucoup différencié avec
des villes comme Grenoble ou des grandes
villes où il y a des il y a des nuances
mais ce sont plus des gradients qui les
distinguent de Paris et les et qui les
distingue encore plus de leur propre
environnement donc noble le centre de
Grenoble est plus proche de Paris que
des endroits les plus reculés de
Auvergne Rhône-Alpes donc
ça c'est vrai mais en revanche la
gouvernance à Paris elle s'est dégradée
c'est à dire qu'on a alors que
l'organisation en métropole a permis des
gouvernements urbains plus un peu trop
petit à l'échelle des agglomérations
plutôt que des aires urbaines ça reste
un problème mais quand même avec une
certaine légitimité notamment à Lyon où
on élit directement les conseillers
métropolitains mais apparaît au
contraire on a rajouté des couches et
donc là il y a eu on a bien vu
d'ailleurs ça se passait sous le mandat
de François Hollande on a vu une
alliance entre les maires des grandes
communes franciliennes le Sénat et
l'État finalement l'état profond qui ne
voulait pas avoir un vrai pouvoir parce
que forcément il serait important pour
une erreur urbaine de 13 millions
d'habitants mais c'est la réalité donc
est-ce que est-ce que les Franciliens
finalement doivent être punis pour
l'éternité parce que ils habitent dans
une grande agglomération il y a quand
même un problème on va laisser cette
question si vous voulez bien et ça a des
effets bien sûr
[Musique]
l'Hexagone est devenu un archipel
d'identité de communauté de mœurs
d'affiliation socioculturelle certains
parlent de désaffiliation
est-ce que Monsieur Piol vous voyez
comment vous arrivez à harmoniser
puisque votre on vous a quelquefois
décrié de certains côtés politiques
comment vous arrivez à harmoniser une
unité géographique avec une unité
politique
socioculturelle et religieuses pour
faire quelque part identité
identité territoriale
identité régionale identité nationale
alors peut-être pour reprendre votre
question dans l'autre sens par rapport à
votre introduction est-ce que la France
est devenue un archipel où ce sont
différenciés des identités ou est-ce que
c'est juste qu'on a perdu un petit peu
de notre affiliation à un projet commun
parce que les différences de mode de vie
je le redis pour moi qui vient de des
frontières à la frontière espagnole d'un
village à la limite gouverné du Pays
Basque jamais la façon de vivre de mon
village n'a été similaire à celle qui se
Prat ici ça m'a fait un choc quand je
suis arrivé un choc de mode de vie de
façon de faire la fête de pratique
chorale de pratiquer économique de
pratiques culturelles donc j'ai eu ce
choc quand je suis arrivé là à 20 ans et
en faisant mon tour de France à
l'occasion de l'élection présidentielle
pour la primaire des écologistes j'ai pu
découvrir des différences de mode de vie
extrêmes donc c'est différent de mode de
vie ont toujours existé ce qui n'était
pas communautarisés si je puis dire oui
et ce qui manque maintenant c'est le
sentiment d'adhésion à un projet qui
tout en laissant ancré dans nos
communautés nous fédères à l'échelle
nationale et là effectivement on a une
désaffiliation que qui est multiple qui
envoie cette France fracturée on l'a vu
au législatives évidemment peut-être
France des sous-préfectures qui a
massivement voté pour le RN et ce monde
urbain qui a voté entre
nupes macronisme et
pour moi c'est l'identité nationale qui
est affectée et c'est ça qui vient du
coup nourrir d'autres formes de
connexion qui se renforcent nous sommes
des multi appartenants communautaires
nous appartenons à différentes
communautés mais si notre lien se réduit
avec le projet national avec un projet
qui nous dépasse alors effectivement il
y a le risque que une de nos communautés
locales tout d'un coup prennent trop de
place donc il y a évidemment le
phénomène de communautarisme religieux
d'un islam politique qui pousse et qui
déborde le cadre spirituel pour essayer
d'aller sur les modes de vie la culture
la politique mais il y a aussi d'autres
replis
identitaires des replis de catégories
socioprofessionnelles les plus riches
qui se replient aussi et qui vivent un
monde toujours plus séparé avec des
inégalités qui grandissent donc la même
vous-même comme idylle vous même quand
Mehdi locale qu'est-ce que vous faites
pour ramener à une cohésion nationale
toute cette disparité des
communautariste
on vous a reproché à certains moments
d'aller vers comment dire des
dissensions si vous voulez
identité
derrière c'est que moi je suis très
scrupuleux sur la loi 1905 donc je suis
très respectueux de cette loi et il me
semble être bonne en état et certains
aujourd'hui comme le disait aimer
Césaire
cherchent à jouer avec les principes de
la République pour d'autres objets ils
négocie avec les principes de la
République pour discriminer tel ou tel
ou pour lutter politiquement mais au
lieu de lutter politiquement sur le
champ politique il se sert de nos textes
fondamentaux pour faire ces luttes
politiques en vous a entendu
alors monsieur vous vous pensez qu'il y
a une fragmentation
identitaire aujourd'hui de la France une
fragmentation communautariste
c'est à dire que les communautés ont
toujours existé il y avait des
communautés de territoire il y avait des
communautés les provinciaux avaient Pays
Basque est un pays une province qui a
beaucoup de traditions et ça existait
les Bretons rappelez-vous qui arrivaient
à Paris à la gare Montparnasse ce même
était était perdu et la Mission Bretonne
qui est créée à proximité de
Montparnasse elle était destinée
justement encadrer des jeunes filles
bretonnes pour qu'elles le sombres pas
elles ne soient pas happée par la
prostitution aux portes de la gare et
qu'elle soit en quelque sorte ou qu'elle
et ensuite souvent c'était souvent des
nourrices des ou des ou des servantes
dans des grandes dans des grandes
familles bourrées
bien sûr ce discriminer ce nom de
Bécassine après on a connu la
discrimination vis-à-vis des Italiens
des Espagnols etc
musulmanes avec un une adhésion très
forte à la religion musulmane pose
peuvent poser un véritable problème
s'était dit pareil par Eric Piol bon
alors lui il a effectivement eu ce
problème de gestion d'une association
dans les piscines grenobloises ils n'ont
pas parlé directement mais je pense
qu'il faut face à des tentatives
d'entrée ou de séparatisme de certaines
communautés ou plutôt de certains
leaders qui sont assez peu nombreux mais
qui n'hésitent pas à aller très très
loin il faut être effectivement très
ferme et la loi 1905 et là il a raison
de la rappeler est-ce qu'il faut pas
inscrire d'ailleurs le principe de
laïcité en discussion avec Michel taupe
vous connaissez certainement qui
voudrait inscrire le plus fermement le
principe de laïcité dans la Constitution
française il faut effectivement il faut
que les mères
essaient d'être dans un certain nombre
de cas d'être le plus intégrationniste
possible mais on peut pas demander non
plus au maire de tout faire parce que on
a tendance dans ce pays où le peu où le
pouvoir politique est excessivement
faible joue sur la peur d'ailleurs sur
la forme de choses à ne plus assumer ses
fonctions principal qui va les assumer
et la fonction d'intégration c'est une
fonction fondamentale à partir du moment
où on accueille énormément de monde sans
doute qu'on accueille trop de monde et
on mélange un peu tout les flux les flux
migratoires économiques l'asile
politique etc on mélange un peu tout il
faut bien évidemment avoir à côté de ça
on l'a jamais eu en France suffisamment
une grande politique d'intégration alors
les maires peut y prendre leur part mais
c'est surtout une responsabilité de
l'État sur cette question du
communautarisme comment vous la prenez
en considération dans vos études d'abord
moi je voudrais faire revenir le débat
sur identité et territoires au pluriel
en France c'est à dire on est tous
porteurs d'identité multiple et
d'appartenance multiple ça a été dit
d'ailleurs un peu par le maire de
Grenoble mais ce qui a été préalable à
l'identité nationale si elle existe
c'est l'identité territoriale en fait il
y a des identités territoriales en
France depuis très longtemps les Bretons
les Normands les
Occitans etc qui continuent d'exister
d'ailleurs c'est des entités elles font
aussi de la richesse du territoire
français de la République de danse à
diversité des modes de vie qui sont
différents des conditions de vie qui
sont différentes etc et encore
aujourd'hui ça reste même un outil
parfois de marketing territorial on voit
bien que les deux capitales régionales
en Occitanie aujourd'hui Toulouse et
Montpellier jouent de cette appartenance
territoriale et donc je sais pas si il
faut appeler ça du communautarisme c'est
une histoire très longue une géographie
une histoire industrielle une histoire
économique et une histoire aussi parfois
frontalière avec l'Espagne avec
l'Allemagne du côté de de Strasbourg ou
de l'Alsace qui font que ces communautés
existent de fait culturellement et il
faut pas considérer que c'est mauvais
d'avoir des communautés culturelles
différentes là on a glissé un peu vite
sur les questions de l'extrémisme
communautaire qui sont en l'occurrence
dans votre question religieuse mais à
mon avis c'est pas ça résume pas disons
le sentiment d'identité ou
d'appartenance au territoire français au
pluriel et et par ailleurs je veux
revenir sur cette idée d'identité
territoriale
comme vous le disiez il y a eu des
Parisiens qui utiliser breton auvergnac
et tenez des cafés etc on est toujours
considéré qu'il était possible d'être à
la fois parisien et breton ou auvergnat
où alsacien il doit pas pourquoi on
pourrait pas continuer de considérer que
dans la République française il y a un
certain nombre d'identités qui face à la
personne à laquelle on se trouve
typiquement quand on est à l'étranger on
est on n'a jamais été aussi français que
quand on est à l'étranger il faut que ce
soit notre appartenance multiple la
différence religions communautés
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a des
fractures identitaires donc c'est la
France c'est vrai que c'est un
territoire pluriel mais Juliette mais
Adèle il y a des fractures
identitaires il y a des fractures
communautaires elles sont politiques
culturelles socio-rigeuses communautaire
comment vous pensez qu'on peut tisser
quelque chose entre tout ça pour quand
même fabriquer un peu d'identité commune
je pense que l'histoire en fait de
France s'est construite dans un tissage
permanent de
d'apport de société de personnes qui
venaient de pays différents alors là on
a quand même une pression migratoire
plus importante maintenant que ce qu'on
a connu même depuis le début du siècle
donc il faut qu'on arrive à tisser mieux
cette espèce de de de
châle on pourrait dire qu'est notre pays
alors il y a quand même une
particularité que nous vivons depuis à
peu près le début des années 80 c'est
que nous sommes traversés par des
mouvements qui sont soutenus par des
typiquement par des groupes qui nous
sont hostiles et je pense évidemment à
tous ces groupes qui entretiennent
l'idéologie salafiste qui entretiennent
l'islamisme fondamental à défendre
politique moi je ne mets pas du tout
dans le même panier ceux qui ont une
pratique religieuse l'islam et qui
personne ne met en cause
parce que moi j'ai entendu beaucoup de
responsables politiques à gauche comme à
droite dire je cite il y a un problème
avec l'islam non il y a pas un problème
avec l'islam il y a un problème avec
l'islamisme fondamental et tous ces
mouvements qui sont en ce moment en
train quand même de se structurer par
exemple dans les universités où j'ai
discuté encore avec un président
d'université ce matin qui me racontait
que il y a des jeunes filles qui sont
qui arrivent
ostensiblement du jour au lendemain avec
une burqa avec un avocat et qui commence
à vouloir déstabiliser l'organisation de
la fac à des fins politiques donc je
pense que là dessus nous avons ici à
dans les émissions nous avons dénoncé ce
vauclisme communautaire voilà donc mes
outils alors comment mais la tresse la
tresse politique c'est la République
enfin c'est Clémenceau la magnifiquement
dit quand on c'est très simple liberté
égalité fraternité laïcité évidemment
tout ça ça doit s'apprendre ça doit se
diffuser ça doit se partager alors
au-delà de la lutte contre les
mouvements comme on l'a dit sectaire à
Visé terroriste qui doivent être fait
par le ministère de l'Intérieur et le
ministère de la Justice au-delà de ça
qui doit être géré par le ministère de
l'Intérieur le ministère de la Justice
et bien c'est un travail d'éducation
permanente il faut faire en sorte que le
projet notre projet la nation
démocratique à la Ernest Renan soit
partagé par tous moi je sais pas comment
on peut accueillir si on n'arrive pas à
faire partager notre projet et si on
n'arrive pas à installer du service
public partout dans tous les territoires
et c'est l'intérêt aussi de votre
émission moi je comprends pas qui est la
diagonale du vide qui est des zones de
désertification médicale qui sont telles
que les gens votent rassemblement
national parce qu'ils se sont
l'impression qu'ils payent des impôts
mais qui n'ont même pas que c'est un
médecin c'est ça l'enjeu de demain c'est
du service public partout sur le
territoire on a disparu Montrouge ou
tout à fait au Grenoble il y a Eric Piol
qui veut qui veut réagir vous vouliez
réagir Eric Piol oui je voulais réagir
sur deux choses puisque j'ai entendu
Jean-Pierre Lecoq dire qu'il voulait
mettre la laïcité dans la solution bon
c'est l'un des premiers mots de la
Constitution française
l'article premier c'est la République
est indivisible laïque démocratique et
sociale donc c'est déjà que faire de
plus dans la confiture que d'INSPIRE ce
principe dès les premiers mots c'est le
deuxième mot porteur de sens c'est
compliqué mais cet article premier
continue en disant que l'organisation de
la France est décentralisée
et c'est pas ce que nous vivons ce que
nous vivons c'est que il y a une
concentration des pouvoirs à Paris
évidemment des prises de décision à
Paris et que nous vivons depuis
2014 un revirement qui a eu un mouvement
de décentralisation pendant une
trentaine d'années de 82 à 2014 pour
faire simple et que derrière nous avons
vécu d'abord trois ans du gouvernement
de Manuel Valls puis encore plus
fortement cinq ans déjà de macronisme
avec une recentralisation des pouvoirs
et donc ça partout en France évidemment
ça se sent les
on voit que les financements ne sont
plus des prélèvements d'impôts locaux
mais deviennent des dotations de Paris
qui dans sa magnitude
nous lance quelques millions d'euros et
donc tout ça évidemment des conséquences
et donc la réaction à ça c'est
effectivement que les territoires de
chacun bien viennent se ré-ancrer dans
une histoire plus locale pour les
Occitans pour les Basques parce que il
faut retrouver du sens et là où Paris
est en train de vous entendre je vais
demander je vais demander à Jacqueline
pourquoi aujourd'hui Jacques Lévy dire
la République toute la République que la
République ça ne suffit pas à créer ce
lien national parce que il faut bien le
constater
oui parce que en fait pour reprendre
votre question de tout à l'heure
qu'est-ce qui se passe avec les
communautés les communautés globalement
je dirais à l'échelle mondiale et
historique elle s'affaiblissent parce
que il y a l'individu qui s'affranchit
des communautés et donc on assiste à un
combat titanesque je dirais à l'échelle
mondiale dont par exemple la guerre en
Ukraine est aussi une expression est-ce
que c'est sur la base du nationalisme
qui est un communautarisme le plus
sanglant de tous les communautés bien
d'accord ou bien est-ce que c'est sur la
base des valeurs que on construit une
société et on l'a aussi chez nous parce
que personne n'a cité le mot Europe mais
en fait ce qu'on est en train de vivre
avec la construction européenne c'est
l'invention de ce que Habermas appelé le
patriotisme constitutionnel c'est à dire
que l'attachement à l'Europe il croit
sur la base d'une adhésion à des valeurs
alors que ce que vous appelez la
République c'est-à-dire en fait
l'association entre des valeurs et puis
un état particulier qui est la France
c'est une espèce de mixte entre une
prétention universaliste mais aussi un
particularisme national et en fait la
manière dont l'État français arrivait à
gérer ses communautarisme territoriaux
ou religieux c'était parce que il y
avait la guerre c'était parce que il y
avait le nationalisme le sang qui
faisait que les Français se retrouvaient
dans les tranchées par les pas la même
langue d'ailleurs en 1914 pour la pour
la plupart mais ils avaient une espèce
de le destin tragique commun et donc ça
de toute façon c'est fini c'est pas fini
parce qu'on a peut-être un retour de la
guerre en Europe pas pour les mêmes
raisons ça sera pas une guerre de
nationalisme ou d'impérialisme contre
impérialisme ou nationaliste donc en
fait la grande question puisque comment
on tisse aujourd'hui d'abord on tisse
plusieurs niveaux il y a pas que la
France il y a aussi le niveau local dont
on parlait Éric Piol il y a le niveau
régional il y a le niveau européen et il
y a le niveau mondial parce que avec les
enjeux de rester si vous voulez bien
rester en France si vous voulez bien non
il faut y rester en permettez-moi
d'hétéroger Éric Piol sur la question
des traditions parce que les traditions
vont avec la modernité et vont avec une
actualisation de la République on vous a
fait le reproche pas qu'à vous mais aux
écologistes d'être contre certaines
traditions par exemple sapin de Noël par
exemple le foie gras on a proposé
d'interdire la corrida la chasse etc
quel est votre position à vous sur ces
questions là et est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est un faux procès qu'on fait aux
écologistes
sur cette deuxième partie évidemment
c'est un faux procès mais ça c'est un
peu normal puisque les écologistes qui
jusqu'à présent il est plutôt des
contre-pouvoirs donc on est traité comme
de gentils adolescents un peu turbulents
potentiellement intéressant et
maintenant qu'il y a une revendication
d'accession au pouvoir locaux agreneurs
en 2014 et puis un peu partout en 2020
et puis nationale j'espère pour 2027
évidemment que la confrontation devient
plus forte et donc il y a tous ces
privés
les traditions pour moi qui suis Basco
Bernay évidemment vous comprendrez que
mon mon héritage je pense que la
transmission est extrêmement importante
après les traditions ça n'est pas le
conservatisme les traditions se
réinterrogent
pour ou contre la chasse par exemple
vous êtes pour ou contre sur les
questions de la chasse de la corrida du
foie gras de toutes ces histoires là
est-ce que ça fait partie de la France
est-ce qu'il y a pas des traditions sur
lesquelles on peut passer si vous voulez
non la corridate est un bon exemple moi
je viens d'un pays corrida j'allais il
faut les interdire ou pas oui il faut
les interdire la corrida j'ai évité le
sujet maintenant longtemps si je peux me
permettre de m'exprimer on a très peu de
temps excusez-moi mais
pas la discussion sur le sujet si vous
voulez pas entendre oui donc j'ai évité
le sujet longtemps parce que je venais
d'un pays de corrida et de fait la
corrida aujourd'hui n'a pas de sens et
donc il faut abroger la corrida en
France c'est une exception d'ailleurs
légale il faut abroger la corrida mais
ça veut pas dire que les traditions en
général sont mauvaises c'est comme
toujours il faut transmettre et
questionner nos traditions la transition
de ne pas avoir le vote des femmes
n'était pas une bonne tradition on l'a
arrêté sur le tas c'est pas la même
chose la corrida et le vote des femmes
c'est quand même le rapprochement est un
peu rosé c'est juste pour dire que les
traditions ne sont pas immuables on
c'est très bien alors écoutez permettez
que j'interroge aussi nos autres
intervenants sur la place de la
tradition on a peu de temps donc
Jean-Pierre Lecoq pour le maintien des
traditions mais dans un certain nombre
de cas il faut les faire évoluer
c'est votre avis Juliette mais adepte on
a pas rejeté un principe ou une valeur
parce qu'elle est traditionnelle le fait
qu'elle soit traditionnelle ne la
disqualifie pas la laïcité est une
tradition française depuis un certain
nombre d'années et je pense que c'est
une bonne tradition parce que c'est
aussi ce qui fait qu'on a qu'on partage
des des principes en commun c'est quand
même le c'est quand même aussi
l'histoire à un certain moment qui qui
permet de tisser ce lien et donc vouloir
toujours tout bouleverser tout le temps
pour le bouleversement n'est pas
nécessairement bon en revanche ceux qui
relèvent de mauvaises évolutions et de
mauvaises tendances et je pense
évidemment au machisme à la misogynie
qui infiltre les inconscients qui
d'ailleurs peut conduire à rapprocher la
broche bien sûr de avec la question du
vote des femmes doit être combattue
parce qu'il y a des il y a des choses
qui relèvent
un exemple de mauvaise tradition
je sais pas si ça va venir comme ça mais
je pense qu'il faut quand même se garder
effectivement de conservatisme c'est les
traditions elles sont quand même issues
d'un contexte et donc dans un contexte
donné là on en a très peu parlé mais en
fait l'évolution des territoires
aujourd'hui elle est très liée aux
enjeux du changement climatique de
l'érosion de la biodiversité et toutes
ces questions environnementales et c'est
pas impossible de se dire qu'une
traduction qui est né dans un
environnement qui était favorable par
exemple la chasse ou le foie gras qui
était favorable parce que il y avait une
capacité de d'accès à l'alimentation ou
au gibier qui était forte elle est plus
aussi favorable dans un monde où la
biodiversité est en train de s'éroder il
faut enfin moi je pense aussi qu'il faut
interroger les traditions au regard de
la société dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui et des défis auxquels elle
est confrontée j'ai pas exemples précis
en tête mais je suis convaincu que c'est
pas immuable une tradition par contre si
on élargit un peu cette idée tradition
par exemple sur la gastronomie on voit
bien je le disais tout à l'heure un
français à l'étranger il se sent très
français parce que il a quand même ancré
dans lui dans sa culture plus que
peut-être que dans son identité terme
que je récuse un peu à l'échelle
nationale des choses qui font partie de
la vie de la vie quotidienne de français
quel que soit leur origine elle leur
appartenance et qui sont très fortes et
fortement créées
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la société de consommation
consomme tout
c'est mars qui disait qu'on en est même
à consommer des rêves
Jacques Lévy est-ce que vous qui avez
beaucoup travaillé sur la question de
justice spatiale qu'est-ce que signifie
cette fringale de nature de biodiversité
contre laquelle Bruno Latour s'est élevé
en disant qu'il fallait pas consommer la
nature mais qu'il fallait habiter avec
elle
oui habiter la nature je pense que c'est
un beau projet
habité c'est un projet humain c'est
c'est lié à l'humanité donc je pense
qu'on est en train de vivre
l'intégration par les humains de la
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la nature ce
qui ne faisait pas partie je dirais de
leur tableau de bord jusqu'à il y a
quelques décennies en revanche les
tendances à l'animisme un nouveau type
de religion immanente ou les fleuves les
glaciers seraient dotés de personnalité
notamment de personnalité juridique là
c'est une bascule je dirais un peu
anti-humaniste qui qui à mon avis est un
danger pour le fait que les humains
soient soit responsables mais avec
l'idée d'accroître leur liberté la
liberté la responsabilité vont de pair
il y a un courant actuellement
chez les écologistes radicaux je dirais
qui consiste à dire que la
responsabilité vis-à-vis de la nature
doit diminuer notre liberté donc ce sont
effectivement des bifurcations
politiques non négligeables je pense que
les sociétés vont avoir à se prononcer
sur ce débat ou partager ce point de vue
LNP skin que les
il y a cette espèce de les gens
cherchent à se goinfrer avec tout y
compris avec la nature alors que c'est
un élément de liberté d'épanouissement
je dirais qu'on sort d'une période où on
a une relation effectivement plutôt
prédatrice ressources et à la nature
dans l'idée qu'elle est finalement ces
ressources étaient infinies et on se
rend compte et de plus en plus vite que
elles sont non seulement elles sont
finies mais qu'en plus elle sera raréfie
au point que on pourrait en manquer et
devoir changer de modèle de
développement donc l'interaction plus
grande entre ce qui fait l'écosystème
vivant entre les humains et les ce qu'on
appelle parfois les non-humains j'aime
pas beaucoup ce terme mais donc tout ce
qui fait le vivant dans l'écosystème qui
contribue à faire fonctionner aussi
l'humanité c'est vous avez une bonne
chose et pour revenir à la question de
l'identité et territoire on voit bien
que c'est aussi un mouvement qui va vers
mieux connaître son territoire ça ses
ressources locales que ce soit des
ressources humaines d'ailleurs des
savoir-faire historiques ou des
ressources matérielles minières
puisqu'on est en train de rouvrir des
mines pour être plus autonome sur les
terres par exemple des ressources
agricoles des ressources forestières qui
sont depuis des stockage de carbone à
proximité des villes etc donc de toute
façon ce mouvement vers une meilleure
connaissance de ce sur quoi on est assis
et comment est-ce qu'on garantit que ce
soit dans la dans la durée pérenne il
est il est il est indispensable face aux
enjeux du changement alors Eric pure
alors on a très peu de temps chacun va
dire sa mot là-dessus quand vous vous
réveillez le matin vous connaissez ce
poème j'aime bien le bruit de l'oeuf dur
cassé sur le comptoir des tâches et je
me trompe pas c'est de Prévert vous
quand vous vous réveillez à Grenoble
c'est quoi
ce qui fait-il moi j'ouvre la fenêtre et
je vois la montagne et je me dis voilà
ça c'est extraordinaire c'est un
émerveillement quotidien et
effectivement changer notre liberté en
fait le but est pas de réduire notre
liberté c'est de requestionner est-ce
que notre liberté c'est la liberté de se
détruire entre humains de détruire le
vivant ou est-ce qu'on va retrouver la
liberté dans un nouveau rapport aux
limites dans
redéfinissant comme le disait mono
Latour ceux qui est important pour nous
et ce qui n'est pas ce dont nous
dépendons et ce que nous sommes prêts à
changer et donc c'est ça qui m'intéresse
moi dans cette conduite du changement en
oubliant jamais que il y a une affaire
de justice sociale majeure en sécurité
le changement de toute une partie de la
population qui a besoin de sécurisation
pour annoncer tout à fait alors
Jean-Pierre Lecoq vous votre bureau est
face à l'une des plus belles places de
Paris qu'est-ce que ça vaut le
cathédrale vous avez en face de vous la
place Saint-Sulpice c'est quoi votre
Madeleine
le Madeleine c'est de regarder cette
place qui est merveilleuse qui pourrait
se comparer derrière une place de
village un peu plus grande néanmoins
mais plus sérieusement moi je voulais
donner un message d'espoir et rappeler
quand même que la France est un pays de
territoire un pays où néanmoins la
nature est encore belle il faut faire
davantage pour la préserver nos villes
ne sont pas gigantesques comme aux
États-Unis Paris c'est 2 millions 200000
habitants elle est très dense mais c'est
pas une vigieuse on accède encore à la
nature très facilement donc il faut pas
non plus culpabiliser de façon extrême
si on a des pays
peu lourds c'est l'Inde c'est la Chine
on vous a entendu là dessus qu'il faut
venir après un mot sur les sur les
nuisances sonores on a très peu de temps
Jean-Pierre sonore à Paris et les
Parisiens se comme la qualité de l'air
resteront plus nombreux à Paris alors je
vais être Méadel très rapidement votre
petite musique à la fois parisienne et
banlieue ma petite musique de mon c'est
que quand je rentre j'ai la chance de
pouvoir aller travailler à vélo et quand
je rentre à Montrouge et que je traverse
le périph je suis heureuse d'être dans
ma ville qui est plus calme comme vous
le disez et qui est plus apaisante et je
crois quand même que tout le monde tout
le compte en France mais partout dans le
monde commence à partager cette idée que
la ressource naturelle est rare et
qu'elle est précieuse et donc
on va rester sur cette notion de rareté
de préciosité concernant la nature merci
alors je vous devez vous présenter une
brève bibliographie
Jérôme Batou la revanche de la province
c'est un livre un peu manichéen qui dit
que la province c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui a tous les avantages
aujourd'hui et que Paris est un peu
délaissé je voudrais également vous
signaler cet ouvrage d'Hervé Le Bras
tableau historique de la France comment
les gens votent sur quelle base et si
vous voulez comprendre pourquoi
l'abstention est grande et pourquoi il
en trouvant du sens la question du sens
je crois habite beaucoup la jeunesse et
petit à petit va nous habiter de plus en
plus je voudrais signaler de Jacques
Lévy géographie du politique
on pourrait dire aujourd'hui politique
de la géographie non tellement la
géographie est devenue indispensable
c'est votre avis oui de plus en plus
pour des raisons
du changement du monde effectivement la
dimension géographique elle est de plus
en plus
patente parlante notamment vous diriez
aussi qu'elle permet de mieux comprendre
l'histoire oui tout à fait mais on
partage ce sentiment alors le Picard est
publi de très nombreuses publications
les parmi les dernières je voudrais vous
signaler régénérer une petite ville sous
double influence métropolitaine alors
c'est le cas de rive de Gières c'est où
rive de Gières c'est la
banlieue de Saint-Étienne mais c'est
aussi un peu sous influences évidemment
de la métropole de Lyon et donc dans une
vallée très industrieuse historiquement
minière qui a beaucoup subi la des
industrialisations et donc c'est le
récit d'une renaissance d'une possible
Renaissance en tout cas dans le contexte
actuel de cette petite ville et je
voudrais également signaler la métropole
géographique et ses urbanismes donc une
autre publication du Puka Jean-Pierre
Lecoq vous avez un livre à signaler j'ai
commis un essai je les voulais pas
amener en 2018 qui s'appelle une
certaine idée de Paris cette année 16
sur le gouvernance de Paris et je peux
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui 80 après il y a
pas grand chose à changer ça rappelle
une certaine idée de la France et
peut-être quelques filiations politiques
oui voilà et je voudrais alors vous
remercier mesdames messieurs merci
monsieur le maire de Grenoble d'avoir
été avec nous depuis vos montagnes comme
vous dites
merci à l'équipe d'elcp et avant de nous
quitter je voudrais vous soumettre cette
pensée la distance dans la proximité la
proximité dans la distance voilà le
paradoxe qui règne aujourd'hui sur tous
nos efforts pour reprendre les héritages
culturels du passé pour les réactiver
sur un monde
[Musique]